welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss the everlasting magic of the
infinity stones in the mcu was
re-examined yet again in marvel's what
if which recently introduced an
alternate universe ultron who not only
succeeded in fusing his consciousness
with the vision synthesized but went on
to acquire the six infinity stones and
blaze a warpath through the multiverse
we thought we were done with these
rainbow space turds but somewhere
between their supposed retirement and
end game and loki calling them
paperweights and what if now inventing
new rules for them the mcu just keeps
flushing them back up well since marvel
has confirmed what if is official mcu
canon with implications on the live
action titles we gotta explain these new
rules for the infinity stones like what
happens when they come from alternate
universes how did ultravision get them
all and what new abilities do they give
you other than the ability to look
amazing in adventures end game thanos
told the avengers that he atomized the
stones after using them but since the
ancient one told bruce banner that the
stones are needed to maintain the proper
flow of time the filmmakers have since
explained that the energy of those
atomized stones still courses through
the main mcu universe and then in loki
we learn that the tva collects
duplicates of the infinity stones as
evidence using them as paperweights this
past week actually the endgame director
zarusa brothers responded to chris
killian parodying this apparent
de-powering of the stone's relevance
[Music]
but really the implication of loki was
the stones were only powerless inside
the tva the dimensional boundary drawn
by he who remains that includes the tva
offices the void and citadel in these
neutral zones the stones are deactivated
carbon copies however their infinitely
powerful counterparts continue to exist
in the sacred timeline playing their
crucial roles in the mcu history so
those are still every bit as important
to the events of stories like avengers
in-game now we have also learned that
there are separate universes within the
marvel multiverse each with their own
set of infinity stones that exert power
within those universes and in what if
allowing us to learn new things about
them and what if episode 1 the tesseract
and space stone which before them was
only supposed to open teleportation
portals in space seem to open a portal
to another dimension to release a squid
demon as well as a portal through time
to allow captain carter to travel to the
present day now you could argue maybe
this just opened a portal to some other
dimension where time didn't exist like
the dark dimension or the quantum realm
places where time is a more fluid
allowing time to be bent in a way to
spew peggy back into the present day but
then in what if episode 4 doctor strange
uses the time stone to try to save
christine palmer but the stone's
temporal manipulation turns out is
limited by certain absolute points in
time however through absorption of
enough demonic entities one can toggle
the time stone's green magic to red
bypassing that absolute point to exert
greater control over all of reality but
melting that reality in the process
[Music]
what if episode 5 established that the
mind stone emits a sub-frequency that
staves off zombies and might reverse the
virus's effect on the brain's limbic
system essentially turning decaying
undead cannibals into normal sentient
humans again don't know how that would
work with their bones exposed but i
guess there'd be a bit of scabbing and
then what if episode 7 introduces
ultravision ultron's successful fusing
with vision complete with vision's mind
stone and the other five infinity stones
in his chest plate now ultravision must
be from an alternate universe because
these thor centric events must be set
around 2011 which would be years before
tony stark would be able to use the mind
stone to activate the ultron ai to begin
with but hey while you're home catching
up on these latest marvel series or
binging an old series you could actually
be enjoying a cocktail made by an expert
bartender a bartender named your name
because shaker and spoon is a monthly
cocktail subscription box that delivers
a craft cocktail experience right to
your front door each monthly box comes
with three original recipes themed
around one liquor and enough ingredients
for 12 cocktails so here's what i got in
my box got a little ingredient list here
got some rosemary beetroot juice some
tonic water a bottle of sparkling spring
water what else we got in here oh some
organic maple syrup from vermont and
then some bitters and botanicals some
other bitters and botanicals and some
honeydew syrup and then some directions
to make a nice cocktail with some
whiskey i'm so excited to get started on
this i just really like how these boxes
come with everything you need to make
the cocktails so you don't have to hunt
down ingredients or buy full-size
bottles of the things that you'll end up
using once maybe you can try out a new
cocktail with just the stuff you need to
make that cocktail all right so i am
going to make the hawassi river water
recipe
[Music]
oh that's pretty nice
i like that it's got a
it's not the flavor i expected it's it's
got a nice sweetness to it and um
i'm gonna drink a few of these shaker
and spoon introduces you to new spirits
and flavor combinations they include
easy to follow instructions and
supplemental how-to videos to get you
making impressive drinks without feeling
like you're studying for the bar exam so
click the link below and use the code
new rockstars at checkout or go to
shakerandspoon.com
newrockstars for 20 off your first box
getting craft cocktails delivered right
to your door is a great way to brighten
up an evening in that
shakerandspoon.com new rockstars or just
click the link below and use the code
new rockstars for 20 off your first box
and so by this logic possessing all six
infinity stones also evolves the
possessor into something akin to a nexus
being who can transcend realities
something we also must keep in mind for
zombie thanos who is right on the brink
of acquiring that sixth stone but how
could ultravision have acquired these
stones in ultron's universe if we assume
the evolution of his ultravision form
occurred around 2015 he would have had
to steal the time stone from the ancient
one the power stone from xandar the
space stone from asgard and the reality
stone from nowhere and then the soul
stone would be a bit harder to come by
because he would have to sacrifice a
loved one on vermeer and who would
ultravision love you could argue if his
assimilation were to happen a bit later
than age of ultron say after vision
melted wandas and our hearts with that
money line about grief a sacrificial
loved one hurled over the vormir cliff
in exchange for the soul stone could be
wanda maximoff in that universe but note
the configuration of the stones on
ultravision's chest for thanos gauntlet
he started filling an empty stone slot
starting with the index finger knuckle
and then working his way down then to
the thumb knuckle and then to the back
of the hand but ultravision would have
started with the mind stone in his head
and then based off of this arrangement
next acquired the soul stone then the
reality stone then the power stone then
the space stone and then lastly the time
stone starting with the mind stone might
have actually helped him locate the
other stones as it was thor's mind
stone-induced vision and age of ultron
that showed him the nesting places of
the stones and maybe ultravision saved
the time stone for last since five
infinity stones would have given him a
better shot against the ancient one
it's also possible that ultravision
could have stolen the stones after they
were acquired by someone else like
thanos in his moment of weakness after
the first snap but before he atomized
the stones on the garden or zombie
thanos in that universe since ultron
centuries would be immune to the zombie
virus but you may be pointing out how it
is pretty surprising to see these stones
even work at all outside of their native
reality because historically in the
marvel comics the infinity stones are
supposed to lose their power once they
leave their home universe reed richards
realized infinity gems are powerless
across realities as we saw during the
incursion events in 2013 and you could
argue this doesn't count but in the
justice league avengers crossover event
darkseid tries to use the infinity gems
in a different reality but they don't
function but here for ultravision to
bridge into this universe take steps
into that desert with his centuries
still all activated red and his six
stones still glowing it would suggest
that in the marvel movies and shows at
least infinity stones can cross
universes and retain their powers as
well as co-exist in a single universe
alongside their variant doppelgangers
more than one space stone more than one
power stone etc etc and while yeah that
seems like too many gloves on a glove
creating potential paradoxes of a time
stone trying to counteract another time
stone well yeah i think that's the point
and it's why uwatu the watcher was
caught so off guard and will probably
finally intervene to prevent the whole
multiverse from disintegrating the way
it did for strange supreme when he
violated natural laws but i think the
combined experiences among uatu's
recruits when it comes to these
experimental uses of infinity stones
will form their battle strategy in these
final two episodes because captain
carter can use the knowledge that the
space stone releases the same squid
demon that strange supreme faced and
strange supreme knows how to take the
time stone way too far and we know from
the trailers that using zombies in some
way is gonna be a tactic zombies great
idea so yeah i think ultimately this
team will try to further cross the wires
of ultravision's infinity stone
collection to entangle the multiverse as
much as possible in order to give each
of them some home field advantage in
doing so while i assume eliminating the
multiversal threats of ultravision and
the zombie virus for now will probably
leave the multiverse in a chaotic state
of characters stuck in the wrong
realities which is the same status we
will find ourselves in in spider-man no
way home and multiverse of madness so
the tldr of this yes the infinity stones
are back but they shouldn't be and
that's part of why the multiverse is
getting too mad you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]